when i look at the sketches i really
appreciate how much work goes into
everything the writing the production uh
and and even down to the the the actors
that you get in the background the
actors
the experts the extras for support
everybody's perfect
do you spend a lot of time working to
get the extras just right
we do i mean we have a really good
extras casting person and and we try to
because they they help create the world
the way you want the world looks if
you're on a pirate ship you want extras
that
look like craggy old pirates and stuff
and and they're amazing we had a scene
this this
season where we're in a plane that's
hitting air pockets and a lot of
turbulence
and there's like 25 extras and the
director is just yelling at all them
he's like
and and up and they're all up and then
to the left
and they were all amazing it's
terrifying it's terrifying it looks
terrifying like the right kind of amount
of fear
everything was perfect they were great
and they're actually they're called
background artists background artists
yes
i believe we're not allowed to say
extras anymore that's derogatory yeah
yes yes it's little people and
background artists yes
got it as they do that so it's it's very
important part of our show
but uh you know without fail once a week
we get one background artist who uh
just i guess is
[Laughter]
it always seems like there will be a guy
who just has to take it upon himself
this is his moment
he's going to do something flashy and it
he becomes the the
catalyst for the scene you know so you
know there was one there was one scene
where we were uh signing the declaration
of independence and
it was a scene about if i went back in
time and dressed like a founding father
and and
uh protested the second amendment before
it was signed and so i
i come in and nobody knows i'm there and
i go gentlemen
and then the the the circle sort of
parts yeah
so we get after the first time we did it
you know i come in there and go
gentlemen
and my man next to me playing john
hancock talking about
and no one's asked him to do that no one
is asked to do that all of a sudden it
became john hancock's idea to talk to
the future guy
yeah about not signing the second
amendment it's like buddy take it easy
see and it's really weird i mean you can
see the other background performers just
getting so pissed at this guy
yeah you know for just taking upon
himself to be the catalyst
um and the same guy was the guy that was
standing next to me going dude
into his phone he was just he was
walking near jordan with his phone i saw
him and took off in the opposite
direction as fast as i could in a sketch
no no we were setting up the camera he's
between sketches and he's just going
boop
you know when someone's doing something
and they they want you to ask
what are you doing yeah and he was
trying to
he just put the line out there i'm like
don't ask
okay what are you doing i'm a musician
actually here's my cd yeah
that's my second album you're going to
love it this song is just something i've
been working on lately
why did i ask why did i ask i asked same
guy
priceless guy you have to ask